I'm not sure if any of you have taken
the necessary pain that is required to
go through Donald Trump's ap interview
it is both simultaneously incoherent and
disturbing the sentences that he
actually was able to string together to
make a complete thought were disturbing
were very unnerving but then even more
so unnerving was just his consistent
inability to give a complete thought
let's bring a couple of it's actually a
transcript let's bring a couple images
up on the screen let's read the first
one in this one and actually pat switch
back so I can set this one up now that I
see this is this is this was something
that I posited on my show early on in
Donald Trump's presidency where he
doesn't know an issue and so he takes
whatever talking points his team gave
him and so once he learns a little bit
about the issue Pat we talked about how
he circled backs and changes his mind on
it almost a complete 180 and this is
what's happened in this first quote with
regard to NATO and that's why you have
to know what you don't know right so you
don't just take the positions of your
closest advisors right exactly and then
so that you don't have to turn and
change your mind in the middle of it but
this is what the first quote does from
the AP take a look at it he said in
regard to NATO he said they had a quote
for me that NATO's obsolete but they
didn't say why it was obsolete I was on
Wolf Blitzer very fair interview the
first time I ever was asked about NATO
because I was in government people don't
go around asking about NATO if I'm
building a building in Manhattan right
so they asked me wolf and asked me about
NATO and I said two things
NATO's obsolete not knowing much about
NATO now I know a lot about NATO NATO is
obsolete let's let's take it there so
it's a little bit more you can read it
but that that's the key part right there
pat that he finally admits that the
reason he said NATO was obsolete because
he didn't know anything about NATO and
now that he knows something about NATO
well all of a sudden it's not obsolete
why are we dealing with this learning
curve
for president who is turning a complete
about-face on every single issue because
he didn't know anything about the job
before he got it well that's your
takeaway from this quote I think that
the more telling part is that last
sentence there where it says that you
know back when they did NATO there was
no such thing as terrorism that's
completely wrong there have been four
waves of terrorism going back at least
to the 1880s starting with the anarchist
wave is a new left wave and we've seen
like a rise in religious fundamentalism
since the 1970s but the idea that
terrorism wasn't a thing when NATO came
around is completely false well and also
he's saying that that NATO didn't focus
on terrorism so that to him the other
part of it is the qualifying relevance
of NATO is whether or not they focus on
terrorism like that he tries to give
that as a way out uh but yeah to me the
thing that stands out the most is that
he just doesn't know what he's doing he
doesn't know the job and he's not
intellectually curious enough to
actually even Google this stuff to check
Wikipedia let alone use his advisors of
all these professionals all these career
experts that could come in and inform
him instead of doing that he definitely
did Google right he didn't know he
didn't know about which I think we
talked about this on the show I with you
last week or two weeks ago he did not
know the relationship between China and
North Korea substantively enough to
realize that he could not just tell
China to throw the hammer down on North
Korea and so this is exposing yet again
that he doesn't know anything about the
job that he signed up for and his excuse
for not knowing much about NATO was that
he was a businessman for most of right
life well then don't run for president
you don't have to know the inner
workings of NATO if you're just drug
business where exactly hotels in your
golf courses but if you decide to make
the choice to run for president
then you've got to know a little better
job you got to learn the job and here we
are as American citizens having the
president literally I remember
Republicans used to complain I'm
choosing my words very carefully here
complain incessantly about Barack Obama
learning on the job no we are quite
literally in gate we're in the middle of
a presidency or at the beginning rather
of a presidency where this guy is
learning on the job
now this was just the first part I'm
actually a little amazed that he
admitted
ignorance that that's almost redeeming a
little bit but it gets worse let's look
at the next slide in regard to uh
the defense contract with uh he said I
saved 725 million on the ninety planes
just ninety now they're over three
thousand planes that are going to be
ordered on ninety planes I say seven
hundred twenty five million it's
actually a little bit more than that but
it's 25 million okay either it's a
little bit more than 725 million or
anyway that's that's that's okay what
could go but the the point in this
particular transcription this particular
point in this transcription is that he's
actually taking credit for something
that he did not do right this is already
been debunked this is not something that
he negotiated this was something that
was already in the process of being
negotiated by the Defense Department and
that was carried out completely outside
of his negotiation skills he likes to
take credit for other people's work he
claims that the job numbers during their
transition was credited to him even
though Barack Obama was still president
right so this actually occurred long
before the election even happened but he
took credit for it now this is still we
haven't even gotten to the most amazing
parts the incoherent nature of this
interview and the narcissism of the
interview so let's take a look at the
next part and this is all in print so
this is this is him getting caught in
the middle of a lie he said Trump okay
the one thing I've learned to do that I
never thought I had the ability to do I
don't watch CNN anymore the AAP says you
just said you did the Trump said no no
if I'm passing it what what did I just
say
the AP replied you just said we're we're
two minutes ago this is hilarious as I'm
reading it Trump said no they treat me
so badly no I just said that no I what I
said I stopped watching them but I don't
watch CNN anymore up pat I feel Dumber
every time I read Donald Trump not not
listening to him like listening to him
you can hear the hustler in the UK here
he's just a fast talker he's trying to
get over on people he thinks aren't
smart on him but when you sit down and
read his words the the fact that he lied
in the middle of a single sentence in
the
in the same sentence he reversed course
and I said I don't watch the Indian but
I watch CNN and then he's being called
out by the AAP but then you see the
incoherent nature of it it is I feel
like IQ was just literally draining out
the side of my ear I think what he was
trying to do there was insult CNN by
saying that you know their fake news I
can't even stand to watch them anymore
but he always has TVs going on in the
background and sometimes maybe Fox's on
instead but he's watching CNN yeah yeah
it is and I wonder if it said no I want
to be so used to getting away with lying
because people around him when you're a
billionaire who's really going to call
you on your lies who's really going to
be that person like I like I'm not even
a millionaire you know I'm not even a
hundred thousand there but I like to
surround myself with people who will
call me all my crap or will expose like
what I need to improve on I think once
you get to a certain income level people
are just so ready to be your yes-man
that they're not going to tell you that
you lied and so now he's finally being
confronted with journalists who will say
no mr. president you're lying and it's
not just that he's rich he's also
someone who inherited his wealth so he
came from a position where he just
deserves everything he has and he's like
an heir to the fortune it actually gets
worse everything we've done so far it's
really not even the bad part let's go to
the next one he said you did put out
though as a candidate you put out a
100-day plan this is from the AAP do you
feel like you should be held accountable
to that plan somebody yeah somebody put
out that concept 100 a plan he's not
even taking responsibility for his
contract with America
I I don't know I let's keep going I
don't even to give any more commentary
on that it's so obscene so absurd this
is the next clip the next segment he
said Trump in regard to WikiLeaks I
never heard of WikiLeaks I never heard
of it when WikiLeaks came out all I was
saying was well look at all this
information here this is pretty good
stuff no I found it very interesting
when I read the stuff and I said wow
it's just a figure of speech
I said well look at this it's good
reading okay then AP Paulette this is
this is really this is how he talks in
writing
the AAP followed up said but that didn't
mean that you supported what Assange is
doing and Trump said no I don't support
or unsupported what the hell is
unsupported I have no idea and is he
talking about the 2016 election
WikiLeaks or is he talking about back in
2010 the Chelsea Manning III should know
about that I'm sure he should know about
that but I I'm afraid to draw that
distinction only because you know he's
going to make us look as ridiculous as
he is because he could be talking about
it he could be talking about nothing and
it's quite frankly what he does and I
know this type of person I noticed I
personalities this is if Donald Trump
wasn't a billionaire he'd be a side
street hustler so who's just talking
really fast trying to get over all right
this one is the one that really bothers
me he said on on any on air talking
about CBS Face the Nation host John
Dickerson Dickerson had 5.2 million
people it's the highest for Face the
Nation or as I call it D Face the Nation
it's the highest for D Face the Nation
since the World Trade Center since the
World Trade Center came down it's a
tremendous advantage um
Pat in this clip in this segment he's
talking about the ratings that he got
when he was on Face the Nation with John
Dickerson and he compared the ratings
that he got would face the nation to the
ratings I don't even know why we would
say ratings in September 11th in the
same sentence yeah he's been using 9/11
to his advantage for a long time even
after the towers came down I think it
was maybe a week or so after he was
boasting about how his building in
downtown Manhattan was now the tallest
in the area and it's it's painful to
consider that his narcissism runs this
deep that he's comfortable I mean he's
demonstrated you're right he this should
not be surprising to me because he's
done it already but he demonstrating yet
again that he's willing to use the lives
that were lost on September of 11th as
props for his own personal gratification
he also claims in a debate that he lost
hundreds of friends in 9/11 and then
when asked to name just one of them he
couldn't do so hundreds of friends would
mean that he knew at least 10% I guess
of the victims there so in its in one
interview you see him caught in a lie in
the middle of the same
sentence you see him admit to not
knowing anything about the job not know
anything about NATO and you also see a
masterful display of his gross
narcissism that he's worked so gross
that he's willing to compare his ratings
when he was on Face the Nation with the
with the ratings that the base nation
got after September 11 I this is this is
your this is our president I was going
to say this is your president but I
guess he's as much mine as yours
it is really tough reading those quotes
and having to see who they're attributed
to at the bottom there and having to put
President Donald Trump in a sad
situation that's a yes I have nothing
else to say about that